did you see Drew Barrymore yesterday
with Dylan Mulvaney you probably did
this was on Drew Barrymore's show
Drew who I generally like as a public
figure she seems very likable and
charming and delightful she was
interviewing Dylan Mulvaney this
transvestite man who performs this wild
caricature of a woman and seems to have
a lot of a lot of problems I did an
in-depth sort of exploration of Dylan
Mulvaney which you can find over on my
YouTube channel that went a little bit
viral because I
I think a lot of
Dylan Mulvaney's EX cretion is not about
biology and it's not about sex and
gender identity I think a lot of it is
owing to the fact that he is an actor
people keep forgetting that he's playing
a role so Drew Barrymore is interviewing
him and it
it got weird where do you find the
strength to keep being the joy well I
think having my chosen family and the
people that I love to take care of me
but I also think there's something just
about uh making sure that you're you
don't put something out there before
you're ready and and really just
surrounding yourself with good people
it's interesting because I look at
someone like you and I can't imagine
anybody disliking you oh please do you
know do you want to know ironically who
uh dislikes me the most sometimes myself
put a pause there
so this is the moment that everyone's
focusing on because Drew Barrymore gets
down on her knees almost like if you
were religious maybe you get down on
your knees and pray before an icon or a
statue you're you're in an active
veneration but but before we get into
all that weirdness
the thing about what Drew says she goes
do you know who often hates me the most
sometimes is myself
and it's a sort of a saccharine line but
I'm sure this is true of a lot of people
everybody has self-doubts everybody has
insecurities
everybody
kind of hates themselves sometimes
especially you think about your teenager
your angsty whatever period of life
where you've had a little bit of angst
or something
you have probably felt this way
so then what
then what we can't just leave it at that
you have to ask yourself okay if I hate
myself for what what is causing that
is it because
I have been lied to is it because I have
been abused is it because I am being
treated unjustly well if that's the case
then the way to fix it is to extricate
yourself from that bad situation or from
that bad relationship
or do I have this feeling of hatred for
myself
because I'm doing something wrong and so
it's not that I'm hating myself I just
hate the wrong thing that I am doing in
the same way that you would say about
someone else love the sinner hate the
sin you don't like the things the bad
things that people are doing and so you
want to stop people from doing those bad
things well that same rule can apply to
yourself which is
that people want to just jump to no you
got to love yourself you gotta affirm
yourself baby you you do it you're a
goddess you're the greatest you're the
queen slay yeah no the first thing if
you have a feeling of self-hatred
the first thing you have to ask yourself
is
This Feeling Just am I reacting against
something that I really should hate
maybe not myself but something that I am
doing if so fix the thing that you're
doing
if it's because of a distorted
perception of yourself because of
external circumstances get yourself out
of those circumstances if it's because
of a distorted view of the whole world
we'll fix your view of the world
it reminds me of that C.S Lewis quote
that I always go back to
if you look for truth you might find
comfort in the end if you look for
Comfort you'll find either truth nor
Comfort only soft soap and Wishful
Thinking to begin and in the end despair
if you that feeling is not going to go
away and it's so Central to the the
transgender argument say I feel
uncomfortable with myself I hate myself
I don't like the way I am and so the way
that I'm going to fix this is I'm going
to chop up my body
and that's going to fix my feelings of
anxiety and stress and suicidality
except it doesn't it doesn't this is why
Paul McHugh who pioneered the
transgender transition surgery at Johns
Hopkins he opened the gender identity
Clinic is why he shut it down
is because it didn't really improve
outcomes people were essentially the
same in the long run as they were before
the surgery it's not that they were much
worse off it's not that there were huge
rates of regret they just it just didn't
really help anything so he shut it down
because the source of those problems
is
from a a conflict between one's
delusions and reality or one's Vice and
reality or ways that we are not living
in accord with right reason you're not
going to fix that by just brushing it
over that's the soft soap and that's not
going to lead you it the truth will set
you free the soft soap and The Wishful
Thinking will ultimately just lead you
to a kind of Despair right now go to
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show let
me ask you something when you use the
restroom you always close the door
behind you right you don't want random
passers-by looking in on you so why
would you let people look in on you when
you go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the restroom and not
closing the door okay I love expressvpn
I'm a total Luddite so I barely know how
to use any technology but it's so easy
to use even I can use it you just
download it one click of a button on
your cell phone on your laptop on your
on your iPad on whatever you want I can
say with full confidence expressvpn is
the best VPN on the market here's why
number one expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can stream HD videos with
zero buffering number three expressvpn
is incredibly easy to use
it's that one button you're done you're
good to go if you're like me you believe
your online activity is your business
use our link expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show today get three months free
in a one-year package
expresvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show okay
keep going oh and but
[Applause]
I guess we're gonna do that thing now
like
you've asked me like what I would do to
combat the hate right yeah but what do
you do okay that's a great question now
you've been doing it a little longer
than I have
I love that line you're a lot older than
me Drew Barrymore you crazy old hag all
right now tell me what you think no
that's not a nice thing to say to a lady
Dylan
and then they're both sitting down there
and it becomes very silly when they're
both sitting down because he is much
larger than she is because he's
obviously a man and she's obviously a
woman
and the whole thing is so performative
it's it's something that normal people
recoil from
in this self-love therapeutic culture
let's just talk it out let's just talk
about our feelings and we're going to do
trust Falls and we're just going to
start to love ourselves
you have to love yourself you should
love yourself
to a healthy degree
if you love yourself too much in an
unhealthy way that's called narcissism
if you don't love yourself sufficiently
then you're not going to be able to love
your neighbor
you're not going to be able to love
really at all
when Christ says in the gospels love
your neighbors you love yourself well if
you hate yourself then you're gonna hate
your neighbor too and society's not
going to be very nice
so it is proper To Love Yourself
in an in an appropriate way
so what is that appropriate way where is
that going to come from why would you
love yourself if you feel that you sin
and you fall and you're broken as we all
are
then
why would you love yourself
because you are made in the image and
likeness of God because you are higher
than the other animals because you
possess a rational will because you have
will and intellect because you can
perceive objective reality because you
can reason about things and you can
reason about not just the things of this
world but even the higher things and the
meaning behind those things
that's why
and if as I often point out all of these
issues they always come back to theology
they always come back to religion
because that has to be the fundamental
thing so you might say well I'm not very
religious okay then your theology is
going to be kind of wonky and all the
rest of your thinking all the way down
to politics is going to be a little
wonky too I'm not saying you're you know
completely helpless but
ultimately it's not going to make sense
and if you try to ground a love of self
on just good feelings or unwillfulness
the same kind of sheer willfulness that
that has Dylan Mulvaney insisting that
he is a woman in the face of all
evidence to the contrary
you're not you're not going to persuade
anyone because people are persuaded by
reason and logic and truth they're not
persuaded by will they might
they might submit
they might cower in fear or they might
pretend to believe if if you insist with
a sufficient force of will but you're
not really going to persuade everybody
the thing that persuades people is
reason and logic and Truth the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member and use code
Knowles Canada w-les at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh